y
[Música]
avance informativo de france 24 el
presidente de china xi jinping encabezó
las celebraciones por el centenario de
la fundación del partido comunista de
china el mandatario elogió un nuevo
mundo creado por el pueblo chino en un
discurso frente a 70 mil personas en la
icónica plaza de tiananmen y afirmó que
el pueblo chino nunca permitirá que
ninguna fuerza extranjera abuse de él
desde beijing los detalles los tiene
nuestro corresponsal adrián foncillas
china no recibirá lecciones ni sermones
de nadie cualquiera que intente oprimir
la de nuevo chocara contra el gran muro
de metal formado por 1400 millones de
chinos lo ha dicho esta mañana sin pin
en el acto central de las celebraciones
por el centenario del partido si ha
recordado las penalidades pasadas como
el colonialismo europeo o el
imperialismo japonés y ha prometido que
esos tiempos de sufrimiento no
regresarán ha sido un discurso muy
combativo pensado para satisfacer a la
audiencia interna pero que da munición a
los que desconfían del auge pacífico de
china es seguro que del acto de hoy se
recordara más el listado de amenazas que
el de los logros como por ejemplo la red
donde la pobreza ha sido un acto dotado
de gran simbolismo con el discurso
pronunciado desde el mismo lugar en el
que mao zedong había proclamado la
república en 1949 y que ha contado con
salvas de cañones con helicópteros
dibujando los guarismos del 100 consumo
en el cielo y con cazas de guerra
a partir de hoy la presidencia de la
unión europea pasa a eslovenia el primer
ministro jan enseñanza de 62 años se
enfrentó a bruselas por la libertad de
los medios de comunicación y previo al
periodo de seis meses de la pequeña ex
república yugoslava al frente del bloque
de 27 naciones lanza también es cercano
al primer ministro húngaro viktor orbán
cuyos desacuerdos con europa occidental
se vieron en una cumbre la semana pasada
sobre una ley que prohíbe a las escuelas
el uso de materiales considerados como
promotores de la homosexualidad con
eslovenia en la presidencia se pone de
relieve la creciente brecha dentro del
bloque sobre sus valores comunes
y desde hoy primero de julio entra en
vigor en la unión europea del
certificado sanitario digital
el documento reactiva los viajes entre
los países socios son más islandia
noruega suiza y liechtenstein la
constancia de inmunización a través de
un código qr entra en vigencia el mismo
día que se marca el inicio del
desplazamiento masivo por el verano los
titulares podrán demostrar así que
recibieron la vacuna kobe que son
negativos en prueba pcr o antígenos o
que se recuperaron de la enfermedad en
los últimos seis meses en paralelo la o
ms alertó sobre el aumento de contagios
por primera vez en el continente tras
diez semanas a la baja
en vic decline el descenso de casos de
kobe 19 que se venía dando desde hace 10
semanas en los 53 países de la región
europea de la oms se ha finalizado tu
ven en los tics de la semana pasada el
número de casos aumentó un 10 por ciento
impulsado por más reuniones viajes y el
relajamiento de las restricciones
sociales y singh of souls turís prix
jones y el presidente de eeuu yobái de
en visita hoy miami para ofrecer sus
condolencias por las víctimas del
edificio soft saide que se desplomó
parcialmente hace una semana mientras
los residentes dormían los equipos de
rescate siguen a la búsqueda de víctimas
entre los escombros el número de muertos
confirmados aumentó a 18 este miércoles
con el descubrimiento de seis cuerpos
más incluidos los restos de dos niños
145 personas están desaparecidas y se
teme que estén atrapadas bajo el
derrumbe
aquí este avance informativo recuerda
seguirnos en france24 punto com y
volvemos en 30 minutos con más extras 24